[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 le journal nous sommes le
7 décembre
voici les titres l'inra a fait ses 70
ans et pour l'occasion hier après midi
le centre de recherches de versailles
grignon a ouvert ses portes au public
nous étions sur place nous étions aussi
présent lors de la deuxième édition du
paris saclay invest qui s'est déroulée
jeudi dernier à hec à jouy-en-josas la
journée a permis de mettre en relation
des jeunes startups du territoire avec
des investisseurs et nous ferons un
point à 3 semaines des fêtes de fin
d'année sur les différentes animations à
venir dans le bassin saint quentinois
on débute ce journal avec l'inra qui
célèbre ses 70 ans et pour l'occasion le
centre de recherches de versailles
grignon ouvert ses portes au grand
public
nous étions sur place plus de 1300
agents travaillent ici sur la recherche
agronomique 70 ans que l'inra étudie
agriculture alimentation et
environnement pour cet anniversaire le
centre de versailles grignon a ouvert
ses portes au public
une après-midi de visite consacrée à
l'intensification de la production
agricole l'agriculture les c'est la
chaux j'avais pas mal de promotion pas
particules et pour tout que cette
pollution pesticides donc à l'origine ça
vient vraiment agricole donc il faut
réagir et on réagit à différents niveaux
nous on est en haut niveau c'est plutôt
réagi des points de richesse pour quelle
méthode on peut élaborer quel système d
culture du système de production
diminuant notre dépendance à
l'utilisation des pesticides donc on
essaie de diminuer les doses fondée en
1946 l'inra avait pour mission de
trouver comment nourrir la france après
la guerre un objectif atteint dans les
années 70 depuis la recherche a évolué
vers une agriculture durable et
respectueuse de l'environnement
des appareils qui sont ici mesure les
concentrations en gaz à effet de serre
polluants atmosphériques n'est pas
seulement les concentrations ce qu'on
mesure sur tout ce qui est son taux
spécifiques ici c'est qu'on mesure des
émissions et les dépôts de ces composés
on sait que si on stocke plus de carbone
on va augmenter les émissions de
protoxyde d azote qui est au ciel un gaz
à effet de serre donc il faut trouver la
bonne combinaison de pratiquer imaginer
les systèmes de culture qui permettent
de vraiment trouver le meilleur
compromis pour résoudre pas seulement un
problème et un panel de problèmes l'an
dernier l'inra a déposé une trentaine de
brevets afin de protéger ses recherches
le centre de versailles grignon organise
toute l'année des conférences pour
présenter son travail en mail
accueillera des lycéens pour la journée
internationale de célébration des
plantes vous pensez avoir une idée
lumineuse être bill gates ou encore mark
zuckerberg ce reportage et pour vous hec
paris situé à jouy en josas a accueilli
jeudi 1er décembre
la deuxième édition du paris saclay
invest la journée permet de mettre en
relation des jeunes startups et des
investisseurs
un reportage de miquel et demi d'euros
une journée pour soutenir les start up
était organisée ce jeudi 1er décembre à
jouy en josas hec paris a accueilli la
deuxième édition du paris saclay invest
le concept l'événement organisé deux
fois par an permet de mettre en relation
les jeunes entreprises du territoire
avec des investisseurs le fait
d'organiser à deux reprises dans l'année
cet événement effectivement permet
d'accompagner déjà détecté les start up
il ya de nombreuses créations
d'entreprises innovantes sur le
territoire cet événement permet de
détecter et de les aider à trouver leur
financement
sur les quarante dossiers
présélectionnés dix ont été retenus pour
être présentés devant les investisseurs
parmi les startups pour retrouve moon à
une entreprise créée en juin dernier qui
a trouvé une idée pour lutter contre les
insomnies s'est basé sur des études
médicales qui montre le lien très fort
entre température et sommeil et le fait
que notre température pour s'endormir a
besoin de diminuer quand on n'arrive pas
sans heurts parfois on retrouve n'ont
rien on cherche on cherche la fraîcheur
donc baser sur ces faits on développe un
produit qui permet de suivre le sommeil
et réguler la température de la tête
grâce à l'oreiller donc du corps en
fonction des besoins
autre projet retenu celui de piques
sprint une start up basée à versailles
la firme propose de créer sa propre
carte postale avec ses photos et de
l'imprimé instantanément via son
smartphone qu'il était en vacances parce
que tout simplement j'ai cherché des
cartes postales
j'en trouvais pas qu'ils me satisfaisait
aujourd'hui beaucoup de carpes et at on
assez kitsch et j'étais à côté d'un ami
qui envoyait lui-même ses propres photos
sur les réseaux sociaux est ce que je me
dis que l'idéal ce serait de pouvoir
envoyer moi mes photos sont des cartes
postales que j'aurais exactement le la
carte postale que je voulais envoyer à
ce moment là c'est finalement
l'entreprise trésor qui a reçu le prix
du jury la start up a mis en place un
logiciel pour aider au diagnostic du
génome humain
une troisième édition sera organisée en
2017 dans les yvelines pour le moment
aucune date ni aucun lieu n'ont été
défini les souverainistes re peut-être
trouvé leur porte parole pour l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 en la personne de
françois asselineau fondateur du parti
union populaire républicaine
il souhaite briguer la fonction suprême
pour cela ils doivent d'abord collecter
des 500 signatures
un pari qui s'annonce difficile pour cet
homme politique très peu connu du grand
public c'est lui
françois asselineau cet ancien
conseiller de paris fondateur du parti
union populaire républicaine sous
se présenter à l'élection présidentielle
il tenait une conférence jeudi dernier à
saint germain en laye pour faire
entendre ses idées souverainistes
le jeudi c'est la catastrophe sur mon
sort
vous vous rendez vous pour dit et quand
ça fait que 25 ans on a vu ça serait la
croissance et le plein emploi alors que
c'est le désastre courbes et graphiques
à l'appui cet énarque de 59 ans passé
également par hec défend le fch exit
inspiré du breakbeat le concept
reviendrait en pratique à sortir de
l'europe pour retrouver de la marge de
manoeuvre budgétaire
nous proposons d'en sortir pour redonner
aux français et bien leurs moyens de
décider de leur avenir collectif
la france n'est plus dirigé par les
français elle est dirigée par des
institutions internationales dans
lesquelles les français n'ont plus leur
mot à dire qui s'appelle la commission
européenne à bruxelles
la banque centrale européenne à
francfort et puis l'otan dont le siège
est à bruxelles mais qui dirigeait
depuis washington
un temps membre de l'ump françois
asselineau a flirté avec d'autres partis
avant de créer l'upm en 2007 associé à
l'ultra droite
il réfute cependant toute similitude
entre ces idées et celles du front
national
mais adhérents aux thèses
conspirationnistes il soutient notamment
que la montée de l'état islamique serait
l'oeuvre de la cia
pour le moment ces réunions attire
surtout des curieux j'étais très
perplexe sur 7 sur cette prise de
position du fric site
mais c'est vrai que je me
je me pose beaucoup de questions
françois asselineau part donc en quête
des 500 fameux parrainage en 2012 il
avait déjà tenté de se présenter mais
sans succès seuls 17 élus lui avaient
apporté leur soutien à quoi sert
l'europe à quoi comment fonctionne
l'europe
les réponses à ces questions ne sont pas
évidentes pour beaucoup de français
consciente de cette situation la maison
de l'europe des yvelines a organisé le
mois dernier un séjour à bruxelles pour
une délégation d'élèves et d'élus du
département
il est midi quand la délégation des 30
yvelinois mes pieds sur le sol
bruxellois parmi eux 17 élus et
représentants de missions locales neuf
étudiants et quatre lycéens
pas le temps de jouer les touristes le
petit groupe est attendu au parlement
européen par le député alain lamassoure
pour une leçon explicative loger les
hommes sur ce voyage organisé par la
maison de l'europe des yvelines vise à
familiariser les jeunes avec le
fonctionnement des institutions
européennes
alors aujourd'hui j'ai vu le parlement
européen ensuite j'ai vu un dépôt un
député très été super intéressant
franchement j'ai beaucoup apprécié parle
avec lui on a pu prendre des photos
c'était super intéressante est super
bien l'avenir c'est les jeunes si les
jeunes ne connaissent pas l'europe s'ils
ne se sentent pas citoyens européens
c'est
et mon gagnera pas comme ça la bataille
de l'europe quoi je veux dire il faut
d'abord que les jeunes sachent de quoi
on parle quand on parle d'europe
du côté des élus la visite est loin
d'être inutile il se met à jour sur les
affaires européennes pour pouvoir s'en
faire le relais auprès de leurs
administrés
c'est intéressant pour la compréhension
des institutions européennes pour la
découverte pour expliquer après aussi à
nos concitoyens à nous exactement ce qui
se passe ici
comment les institutions européennes un
flux en direct sur leur quotidien
la journée s'est clôturée sur une séance
dédiée au comité des régions
la délégation a ensuite repris le chemin
de la gare pour rentrer dans les
yvelines
bilan quelques heures passées à
bruxelles auront permis de véhiculer une
image plus concrète de cette entité que
l'on appelle europe
j moins 3 semaines avant noël et bien
sûr à cette période les marchés de noël
fleurissent un peu partout
camille lambert nous a rejoint pour
faire un point sur les animations du
territoire sman alors le père noël a
énormément de travail à cette période je
ne sais pas si le vôtre a déjà trouvé
tous ces cadeaux nouri ferrer c'est un
petit peu compliqué facilement en tout
cas tous proposent de de l'aider en
allant fouiner un petit peu sur les
marchés de noël est une véritable mine
au trésor on trouve un peu de tout de la
gastronomie de pour les cadeaux comme
pour le repas du réveillon artisanat
produits locaux produits du terroir et
même du vin et du champagne mais à
consommer avec modération bien sûr
haussmann et ce week end c'est la ferme
du mas nec est ouvert le bal ça
exactement alors les marchés de noël de
montigny le bretonneux et bois d'arcy
ont déjà eu lieu mais pas de panique il
en reste encore beaucoup jeudi dernier
et l'encours a lancé le top départ de
ces festivités avec les illuminations le
marché lui commence dès vendredi et
samedi et dimanche des animations au
snowpark et mur d'escaladé sont
également a également mis en place pour
les enfants de quoi les occuper pendant
que les parents font leurs emplettes
tranquillement et pour les habitants
c'est un rendez vous immanquable on
écoute jean michel fourgous le maire de
la commune
on va écouter les nouveautés c'est
les tendres qui sont remplacés par des
chalets donc c'est beaucoup plus fixe et
beaucoup plus confortable des des
animations sportives c'est toujours très
attendu c'est ça montre bien dire que
les français sont très attentifs et très
des symboles
il ya des des valeurs et des traditions
il faut pas l'oublier
nos administrés sont très sensibles mais
sur ce type de tradition un moment très
attendu donc aussi un voisin de
bretenoux le marché de noël fête ses 33
ans ce week end c'est à dire 20 ans
avant la naissance
oui exactement pour la date
d'anniversaire j'irai vérifier quand
même cette année encore plus de 90
exposants seront présents créations
d'arts textiles bijoux maroquinerie
décoration et gourmandises évidemment et
pour le plaisir des yeux le marché de
noël accueillera pour la première fois
l'exposition du concours dessine moi
noël un concours au des dessins ou
quatre écoles de la ville ont participé
l'occasion de découvrir le travail et
l'imagination des élèves
la coordinatrice du centre alfred de
vigny fait le point sur les autres
nouveautés de cette année c'est le
centre qui organise cette manifestation
chaque année un petit peu de nouveauté
cette année on va avoir une chorale dans
gi sinoise la chorale cadence qui va
venir qui nous fait l'honneur de venir
inaugurer le marché voilà à 11h30 le
samedi il y aura aussi également j'ai
oublié de dire une grande tombola cette
année pareil ces nouveaux tout le week
end et le tirage au sort aura lieu le
dimanche à 17 heures pour gagner un vtt
voilà bon cadeau de noël et pour les
retardataires il y aura le marché de
noël demeure pas le dernier week-end du
16 au 18 décembre dernier week-end donc
avant le grand jour
le vendredi il sera ouvert jusqu'à 22h
une patinoire de 200 mètres carrés sera
installé pour l'occasion deux fois plus
grande que celle de l'an dernier pour
deux fois plus de glisse alors haussmann
est ce que vous allez chaussez vos
patins
je pense bien oui mais je suis pas très
très fort faire attention parce que
c'est une jambe avant le réveil quand
même merci de me porter la poisse merci
grève ni yves lambert la 7e édition du
salon des arts de plaisir a débuté ce
week-end 20 artistes sont à l'honneur
jusqu'au 11 décembre
des peintres des sculpteurs venus des
îles
de toute la france le public est invité
à les découvrir dans la salle
armande béjart situe à proximité du
château de versailles
on écoute un mot de la direction des
affaires culturelles de la ville nous
parler des objectifs de cet événement
c'est de faire connaître à la population
toutes les techniques artistiques autour
des arts visuels notamment art
marqueterie acrylique vous avez de
l'encré de chine également des
sculptures donc c'est une programmation
qui est assez varié il va y avoir une
remise de prix donc dimanche dimanche
ans descend à 17 heures ici donc toute
la semaine les plaisirs oies sont
invités à venir voter pour leur artiste
favori
et puis on finit ce journal avec cette
information la reconduction jeudi de la
circulation alternée à paris assez sa
proche banlieue en raison d'un pic de
pollution d'une qualité de l'air jugé
très mauvaise seuls les véhicules aux
plaques d'immatriculation pères pourront
circuler
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci
de nous avoir suivis et surtout bonne
soirée
[Musique]